- [Voiceover] Nitrogen
often gets less attention
than carbon or oxygen, but nitrogen is
very important to life as well.
And like carbon and oxygen, it
cycles through our biosphere.
Now, one thing that's maybe
surprising about nitrogen,
if you haven't studied it much,
is that it is very, very
common in our atmosphere.
78% of our atmosphere
is molecular nitrogen,
so it's in the form of N2.
So this right over here
is molecular nitrogen.
You have two nitrogen atoms
covalently bonded to each other.
Now, unlike carbon, which can
be directly fixed by plants,
in the carbon cycle video we talk about
how autotrophs like plants
can take light energy
and use that to fix carbon from the air
into a solid form and store that energy
in those carbon-carbon bonds,
nitrogen cannot be directly fixed
by complex organisms, like plants.
Instead, the key actor that
fixes the nitrogen from the air,
so you have all of these N2
molecules in the air here,
the actors here aren't plants,
but prokaryotes, like bacteria.
So let me draw some soil here.
And the bacteria could be in
a bunch of different places.
But you could have a
bacteria in this soil.
I'll draw them a little bit
bigger so you can see it.
Some prokaryotes right over
here, there's the bacteria.
And certain types of bacteria are capable,
and prokaryotes are
capable of fixing nitrogen.
So what they're able
to do, is they're able
to take that N2 and turn it into a form
that is more usable by
complex organisms like plants.
So this is the bacteria, right over here.
So that's the bacteria.
That's this little circular strand of DNA,
I could draw other--
I could make it more complicated,
but let me just do it like this.
Bacteria is able to fix that N2
and take it to ammonia, NH3.
And it's this ammonia, it's this ammonia,
that is really useful for plants
and other complex organisms.
So this right over here.
So as the plant in the
video on the carbon cycle
we talk about how plants fix carbon,
carbon makes up a large
part of organic molecules,
but many important organic molecules
also need nitrogen.
And these are examples
of organic molecules
that you will find in plants,
and you'll find them in many
different types of organisms.
So this right over here is an amino acid,
amino acid,
we see the nitrogen right over there.
This right over here is
our good old friend, ATP,
adenosine triphosphate,
the quick-store of energy
in biological systems.
You see the nitrogen in
blue right over here.
This is the famous DNA,
deoxyribonucleic acid.
And you see the nitrogens
throughout this macro molecule.
So nitrogen is essential for life,
but the step of fixing that nitrogen
that's done by bacteria, which
can then produce the ammonia,
which is then usable by plants,
and then by eating the
plants, beings like you and me
can get that nitrogen into our systems.
Now, it's not just a one-way street.
That is, we're just
going from the nitrogen
in the atmosphere, and it
gets fixed by prokaryotes,
and then that gets used--
that gets turned into ammonia
and gets used by higher organisms.
Because eventually all of
it would, would get deleted.
As an organism dies, as an organism dies,
let's say this is a dead organism,
it could be a bacteria, but I'll go
with a higher organism,
a multi-cellular one,
this is a dead plant here,
I don't want to draw dead
animals, it's more morbid.
So let's say this is a dead plant there.
And when it gets decomposed,
and there are many
different types of bacteria,
even though I might draw them
kind of looking the same,
let's say this is another
bacteria in orange.
As these bacteria digest these plants,
they're able to, they could
take some of the nitrogen
and break them down into
nitrites and nitrates,
these are molecules
involving a nitrogen bonded
to two or three oxygens,
and they can take them back to ammonia.
So we can go back, so
we can have a bacteria
that take us back to ammonia,
or eventually by converting the nitrogen
into nitrites and
nitrates, we could go back
we could go back to that
molecular nitrogen, that N2.
That then gets released
back into the atmosphere.
So, or it could get, even, you know,
it could get stored in other ways as well.
But, in general, as you
see here, this pattern.
That we have these elements
that are essential for life.
They don't just disappear
or form out of nowhere,
they're constantly being
recycled in our biosphere.
And nitrogen doesn't get as much attention
as carbon or oxygen, but
it is essential for life.
In fact, when you look at
especially plants and growing plants,
and you think about fertilizer.
Fertilizer is something
that you should think
if you add it to a plant,
it's going to grow more.
So without it, it kind of limits
how fast a plant can grow,
a lot of fertilizer is
going to have nitrogen,
and in other video, we're going
to talk about phosphorous.
And that phosphorous and nitrogen
and their availability in the soil,
is often a rate-limiting
factor for plants.
And you know that, because
if you add more nitrogen
or that phosphorous, it will
add more ammonia to that soil,
you're going to, the plants
are going to grow faster.